billions of people around the world are
trying to celebrate this holiday season
with ease and cheer but why do the
holidays always seem to end up sucking
let's start with waste eight million
tons of plastic enters the ocean every
year which is the equivalent of dumping
a garbage truck of trash in the ocean
every minute this problem becomes even
more elevated every year during the
holidays between Thanksgiving and New
Year's Americans throw about 25% more
trash than during the rest of the year
in the UK alone enough wrapping paper is
used to wrap around the equator 9 times
the holidays are also bad for your heart
heart specialists refer to this time of
year as the Merry Christmas coronary or
the Happy New Year heart attack this is
because there are consistently one third
more coronary deaths recorded in
December and January than there are from
June to September cold weather can
actually increase blood pressure but
researchers actually conducted these
studies in the consistently warm Los
Angeles the reasons for these fatalities
is more likely related to emotional
stress unhealthy eating and excess
alcohol yes we do eat and drink a lot
during the holidays there have been
several studies on weight gain
associated with Christmas some studies
found a minimum weight gain of half a
pound while others found a maximum of 3
pounds these same studies claim it can
take months to lose the weight a u.s.
report also monitored 450,000 DUI
offenders and found that their drinking
over the holiday season increased by 33
percent there is so much pressure to
have a holly jolly season that experts
think unrealistic expectations pressure
for perfection and comparing yourself to
others can bring low moves and depending
on where you live there can also be a
lack of sunlight the mechanism of
seasonal affective disorder is not fully
understood but a decrease in sunlight
can affect some people circadian rhythms
altering production of dopamine
norepinephrine and serotonin and finally
there's the dwindling bank account a
u.s. Gallup report found that this year
in 2018 Americans can expect to spend
eight hundred and eighty five dollars on
gifts while a Deloitte survey
anticipates 1,500
$36 in holiday shopping this includes a
17 to 22 percent increase in online
shopping and despite your best efforts
to get loved ones something they like
15% of recipients are unhappy with the
gift they received economists refer to
this as the deadweight loss of Christmas
wear how much the gift giver pays losses
anywhere from 10% to one-third of the
value based on how much the receiver
actually appreciates the gift thanks for
watching you can watch our video
Christmas shopping with a science nerd
there and our new ariana grande
breathand parody there try to enjoy the
holidays even though now you know from a
scientific perspective they suck and
make sure you have subscribed for new
science videos every Thursday peace